wir müssen über die berühmte app reden
herr braun jetzt kommt sie endlich für
mitte juni angekündigt und nun ist sie
auf dem tisch kommt sie zu spät
nein ich glaube natürlich würde man sie
sich immer früher gewünscht haben aber
wir werden in kürze eine app
präsentieren die nicht nur höchsten
datenschutz anforderungen genügt sondern
auch höchsten sicherheitsanforderungen
das ist einfach wichtig wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass die app großes vertrauen in
der bevölkerung genießt und deshalb
glaube ich wir sind nicht die ersten die
eine app präsentieren aber ich glaube im
weltweiten maßstab sicherlich die beste
die beste auch noch halleluja
datenschützer sind zufrieden franken
glauben sie denn noch dass es gute
gründe geben kann sich diese app so sie
denn in der nächsten woche kommt auf das
eigene handy zu laden nicht auf das
eigene handy zu laden also glauben sie
dass es trotz des datenschutzes gründe
geben könnte sie sich nicht auf das
handy zu laden
ich bin auf jeden fall überzeugt davon
dass jeder das recht haben sollte sich
frei zu entscheiden ob er bei diesem
experiment mitmachen möchte oder nicht
und das ist eine sache die mir momentan
sorgen macht dass dieser app sozusagen
als heilsbringer so ein bisschen
präsentiert wird und es wurde ja schon
angesprochen wir haben eine ähnliche app
schon in vielen ländern dass unsere sich
jetzt soweit unterscheidet das würde ich
jetzt erstmal ein bisschen anders sehen
und wir haben eben in den anderen
ländern gesehen das ist so viel gar
nicht gebracht hat weil die technologie
das gar nicht hergibt so genau diese
kontakt verfolgung zu machen und von der
häufig wird an diesem experiment
teilnehmen mir macht es aber große sorge
dass jetzt über eine pflicht diskutiert
wird da halte ich gar nichts von man
kann das auch ganz einfach umgehen dann
kaufe ich mir einfach ein zweithandy
oder lass mein handy zu hause
das kann nur funktionieren wenn alle
mitmachen und es muss eben ein
ergebnisoffenes experiment sein das
heißt mir macht das sorge dass sich
einige behörden jetzt hinstellen und das
sind anpreisen nach dem motto damit
können wir in die normalität zurück ich
glaube das ist ein wunschtraum der nicht
in erfüllung gehen wird
kommen wir gleich zurück herstellt kann
diese app tatsächlich eine wende in der
pandemie bekämpfung bringen oder ist sie
ein mittel um uns auf dem guten weg ein
bisschen sicherer zu machen
also man kann ja nur rein evidenzbasiert
da argumentieren und in südkorea
da scheint zu funktionieren
da ist aber auch ein sehr andere
vorgehensweise also dass der datenschutz
wird er ja sehr anders gehandhabt
ich weiß nicht und dass das müssen
andere sagen ob wir uns da wirklich
ähnlich wie sie das gesagt haben ob wir
uns das so auf einer app jetzt verlassen
sollten dass das der einbringer wäre um
die die pandemie zu bekämpfen länder
auch skeptisch also dann sind wir noch
mal bei ihnen herr braun
sie war ursprünglich immer an notiert um
überhaupt erst lockerungen möglich zu
machen
jetzt sind wir schon längst in den
lockerungen was wird also diese app noch
bringen und wird sie wirklich freiwillig
sein
also die app wird definitiv freiwillig
sein und wir haben auch mit den
unternehmen gesprochen und mit allen
soll lang gar keiner stelle irgendwo zu
irgendeiner bedingungen gemacht werden
die app ist rein eine unterstützung für
mich selber dass ich besser einschätzen
kann ob ich eigentlich einem risiko
ausgesetzt habe oder nicht nur für mich
das heißt wenn ich im bus gesessen haben
eben jemanden den ich gar nicht kenne
der sich später als positiv heraus
stellt in einem test dann werde ich das
normalerweise nie erfahren und über die
app völlig anonym
werde ich diese information bekommen und
das ist ihr einziger zweck und nur ich
habe die information und ich kann mich
dann wenn nicht selber eine solche
warnung bekommen ans gesundheitsamt
wenden und ab da läuft alles ganz normal
wie in analogen welt auch und insofern
ist die app kein heilsbringer aber sie
ist eine riesen unterstützung für jeder
der sein risiko einschätzen will
und insofern wird sie uns nicht davor
bewahren dass wir weiter abstand halten
müssen
das bleibt alles gleich aber sie gibt
mir sicherheit dass ich mein risiko
besser einschätzen und jetzt können
diese
alarme natürlich menschen auch im mit
angst und schrecken ausstatten kann es
irgendwie auch menschen geben die
panisch darauf reagieren
die gesundheitsämter haben sich auch
schon bedankt und haben gesagt das kann
unsere kapazitäten übersteigen
wenn es tatsächlich alarme und auch
fehlalarme gibt wie geht man damit um
also wir werden das intensiv begleiten
es wird rund um die uhr eine möglichkeit
geben auch anzurufen um das einordnen zu
können aber auch wenn diese app
sozusagen ein signal sendet dass jetzt
von einem hohen risiko auszugehen ist
sagt einem sehr klar dass das jetzt
einfach ein punkt ist wo man kontakt
aufnehmen muss um sich weiter beraten zu
lassen und das ist nichts alarmistische
und davor muss auch keine angst haben
sondern das ist einfach eine wichtige
information verein dass man weiß jetzt
muss man schauen und dass man sich
selbst den tod sagen testet und damit
die bestmögliche medizinische versorgung
für sich selber in anspruch nehmen kann
und dass man natürlich auch auf passt
auf alle die um einen rum sind hier
einen wert sind
die einem etwas wert sind das heißt aber
auch sie werden nicht zur pflicht
gemacht nicht im kino nicht im
fußballstadion nicht irgendwo da
schüttelt er den kopf frau könnten sie
sich vorstellen sich eine solche app
auch auf sein die zu laden
also bei mir sind im moment auch noch
viele fragezeichen weil ich habe gelesen
also mindestens 60 prozent müssen daran
teilnehmen und ich denke es gibt
bestimmt ganz viele menschen die haben
überhaupt gar kein smartphone und können
also dann auch die nicht trainieren also
zb einbrecher meine mutter denke die
wird sich noch und die würde ja gerade
zur zielgruppe gehören also deswegen
weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau habe zwar
durch 60% teilnehmen je mehr desto
besser
ich sage mal es wird sehr viel zu hause
ist ist weniger wichtig als diejenigen
die häufig in der bahn fahren und
deshalb häufig in der nähe sitzen von
menschen die sie gar nicht kennen also
es gibt da nicht irgendein schwellenwert
ab dann das waren das sinn ergibt
sondern wir wollen dass viele mitmachen
und je mehr desto besser